en este vídeo veremos cómo conectar los
cables de corriente del controlador del
motor y también los cables del
controlador del motor a nuestro arduino
conectamos nuestro cable rojo en la
entrada de voltaje esta que dice be in
el cable negro va a tierra donde dice g
n de y es importante que estos no se
confundan ahora tenemos nuestros cables
de señal que vienen de nuestro
controlador del motor y que le van a
permitir al arduino decirle al motor a
dónde moverse con qué velocidad y cuándo
detenerse resulta que estos conectores
son hembras pero necesitamos machos pero
necesitamos machos por la forma en que
configuramos nuestro arduino así que
vamos a usar cables para hacer la
conexión empujamos hasta el fondo cada
cable sin aislante y después lo
cortaremos para que entren perfectamente
en las entradas de nuestro arduino
hacemos esto para los cuatro acopladores
y luego los cortamos a unos 5 milímetros
o un cuarto de pulgada o quizá un poco
menos para evitar tener cables expuestos
yo creo que mejor los cortamos a unos
3.5 milímetros es mejor que usemos
pinzas para colocar los cables y como
ven se me acaba de doblar un cable por
lo que voy a enderezar lo
tratar de ponerlo una vez más ya que a
veces no es tan fácil colocarlo ya
tenemos nuestros cables listos y ahora
vamos a poner estos cables de señal en
los puertos correspondientes de nuestro
arduino el primero irá en el pin 11 el
siguiente irá al pin 10
el que sigue irá al pin 9 y el último va
a ir al pin 6 los canales de señal banda
izquierda a derecha y están en el mismo
orden que tienen en el controlador del
motor